well I know what you're thinking how did
this happen
it's Thor coming home to a wreck he's on
a bit of a journey of self-discovery
I think we're first same and it notices
the universes in the state of chaos and
someone back home he's not doing their
job he shows up in his poem is destroyed
and he has to save it and along the way
he runs into Grand Master who's a
funster of the highest order
what have you brought today tell me a
contender
I play Valkyrie who is an elite warrior
who hails from Asgard and she sort of
reluctantly becomes a part of a team
with or surprise this would be such fun
the key for me is being friends with the
actors and people you're working with
and making sure that work is a fun place
to go we're very privileged to work in
this industry and go to sit and pretend
stuff all day for a job we're the same
you know just a couple of hotheaded
fools
yes I'll collect fire boy like water
Tyga's one of those like just lead by
example he comes to set he has a
tremendous amount of energy he's a goof
he loves improvisation we'd start with
the scene and then Tycho would shout
something out we had such a good time
with each other you can feel that
we know each other is a friend from work
[Music]
[Music]